[Musique]
frank sheeran c'est bien ça oui c'est
bien ça selon votre contrat le
management de police ancien chauffeur
qu'en cas de faute lourde
alors vous êtes parfois en retard les
infractions au code de la route non ou
buvez au travail
non vous n'avez frappé personne au
travail oui j'ai pas l'impression est
bien dans ce cas nous n'avons pas à nous
en faire vous présente mon cousin
russell de famine eurostar a falli
enchanté
c'était comme à l'armée sur sub et les
hommes sur geste il fallait
pour l'été récompensés
nos amis a désormais en ce moment un ami
qui est à 100 mm et pas une seule
personne dans tout le pays qui ne savait
pas qui était jimmy hoffa toujours
attaqué l'équipe pistolet mais les
couteaux il faut [ __ ] le camp armes à
feu on attaque et poignard on se bat
allez franck tu veux contribuer à écrire
cette page d'histoire
les grandes entreprises de gouvernement
se sont associés pour essayer de
détruire vous faire quelques jours
qu'est-ce qu'il a encore dit c'est pas
marrant d'avoir des secrets entrer en
guerre avec ses filles ok
chose encore dégénéré avec la vram
j'aimais asseyons nous tous les quatre
faut qu'on discute
je refuse de m'asseoir c'est au-dessus
de départ
les jeux sont faits et je sens que je
sais des choses est ce que je sais il sa
part le sénat
et ça se passera comme ça quand on le
veuille ou pas son compte est bon
peu m'importe que que vous l'ayez fait
ou pas en fait ça ne change rien pour
moi et je sais je suis ici pour vous
défendre
ok ok vous vous demandez si je suis
coupable ou innocent et blanc
[Musique]